hi everyone and thanks for joining us
i'm maggie pockela senior
manager of global market development
here at the genetic testing solutions
business unit in thermo fisher
scientific
and i'm joined today by dr manoj gandhi
who's our senior medical director
today i'm going to be having a
conversation with dr gandhi about what
we might expect when coveted 19
meets the flu season hiya dr gandhi
thank you so much for joining me
thanks for having me maggie it's a
pleasure to be here and having this
discussion with you on a rather
important topic
let's dive right in so with sars kobe 2
infections
still spreading around the globe it's
quite apparent that we're going to be
soon be at a point where the flu season
is going to overlap with the covid19
pandemic
so can you share a little bit about what
we already know about
co-infections with stars kobe 2 and
other respiratory illnesses
yeah first let's talk about kovind 19.
kobe 19 is quite a new virus and we as
humans
do not have any immunity to this novel
virus as we have seen in the past six
months
more and more of the population is
getting infected with the virus
if one has to learn from other viral
infections there is a very good
possibility that this virus could become
endemic
in comparison influenza has been around
for about 100 years
however in the early years of the
evolution of the influenza virus
the influence of virus also was very
lethal while today influenza
is still lethal the mortality rate has
dropped because we as humans
has equal have acquired a level of
immunity to this virus
and now the influence of iris is a
seasonal virus and it is in this winter
months
that influenza cases peak in the
northern hemisphere
the problem that we have here is that
this influenza season
will occur while the world is still
dealing with the kovid19 pandemic
now coming to your question as to
co-infections
it is more likely that the patient will
either have one or the other
rather than both infections at once
there is limited data out there to say
if co-infections can or cannot occur
there is a very distinct possibility
that the patient is infected with covet
can be in fact the same time with
influenza or vice versa
when one looks at the studies that have
been conducted the most common viruses
that are associated with coping 19
happen to be rsv influenza a
influenza b and other rhinoviruses
however the most likely situation
would be that the patient who presents
to the hospital as either one or the
other
and the odds of being co-infected are
rather small
another realistic possibility is that
the person gets infected with one virus
then recovers from the illness and after
sometimes falls sick
with another virus however if a patient
does get co-infected with influenza for
example
while we don't really know what the
exact course of the disease would look
like it is certainly expected to be much
worse
than if it would be once at one at a
time
that's really interesting so with all of
that in mind
what are your thoughts on how this might
impact
patient management moving forward into
the flu season
one of the issues that our medical
community has been concerned
with the flu season overlapping with the
pandemic is the whole issue of patient
overload
until last year you know when kobet was
not around
hospitals used to gear up for the flu
season and then things would quieten
down after the season is over
however with the pandemic the healthcare
systems especially the emergency
departments and the intensive care units
in places that have been really been
hard hit by the kovic 19
are already stretched to the limit and
now they have to deal with the flu
while no one really knows what the true
impact will be
this is one of the biggest concerns of
the middle community which is
the whole issue of patient overload
okay so with patient overload in mind
and trying to understand what this
twindemoc might be bringing us
um how exactly would somebody clinically
distinguish between these different
respiratory infections
and what role is testing play in here
if you look at these different
respiratory pathogens the problem with
them is that they all present with
rather similar symptoms such as fever
cough body ache and runny nose among
others
there are some subtle differences such
as loss of taste or smell
and shortness of breath that is seen
generally in co-weight patients
however that might not be the case in
all patients and for the most part
the symptoms between cobain and the flu
are strikingly similar
so the issue really becomes is how can
the physician really distinguish one
versus the other
it is very difficult to distinguish
based on just signs and symptoms and one
really really needs to perform a test to
distinguish between these diseases
all right that makes sense so speaking
of tests
i'd like to get your thought on where
test makers especially us here at thermo
fisher scientific
fit in can you share in any of our
upcoming plans
for moving into flu season
yeah it is really up to companies like
thermofisher scientific to make the test
to serve the needs of the physician and
more importantly the patients
we already have a test that has received
emergency use authorization
for the detection of kovit 19. however
with the flu season approaching
what we are doing here at thermo fischer
scientific is to make a test that can
distinguish
covet from flu a and flu b in a single
test
so that with a single test the physician
is able to distinguish these diseases
and make the right decision for the
patient this test is a pcr based test
that with the single nasopharyngeal swab
is able to tell the treating physician
whether the patient has covered
19 or the flu and if it is a flu which
one is it is it flu a or flu b
really exciting i'm looking forward to
it learning more about that soon
so let's also talk a little bit about
therapies for flu
and therapies for covet 19 because i
know we've made progress there
where do these new therapies or existing
flu therapies fit in
so like i said before these the whether
it is covered or flu a or flu b
uh these patients really present with
very rather strikingly similar symptoms
and and most of these
treatments for these patients are mainly
symptomatic so one
really can ask the question why does it
matter to distinguish whether these
symptoms
if they are the same why does it really
matter to distinguish between one versus
the other
while it is true that the mainstay of
managing these patients is mainly
symptomatic
there are some significant differences
in the treatment of kovid patients and
flu patients
what we have learned in in in kovite 19
for example there is an
acute phase of the disease where there
is the release of what we call cytokine
storm
and this can have a negative effect on
the lungs this causes shortness of
breath
that we see in these patients and we
refer to that as an acute respiratory
distress syndrome
this acute respiratory distress syndrome
can actually be treated with steroids
and interleukin 6 inhibitors such a
toxic zoom
in addition to giving these patients
respiratory support such as a ventilator
however when you look at influenza we
generally do not see these cases where
the patients have a cytokine storm
and present with erds hence there is no
real
need to suppress the immune system in
fact in patients with influenza
serums are actually contraindicated and
are known to actually make the disease
worse
by suppressing the immune system and
making these patients more susceptible
to secondary bacterial infection
similarly there are very specific
antiviral treatments that have been
approved for the treatment of copay 19
versus influenza
for example there is rem death silver
that has been approved for the treatment
of kovid19
whereas it has not been tested in
patients with influenza
similarly antivirals such as
osceltamiver and xana member
have been approved for the treatment and
influenza and have not been
approved for the treatment of kovid19
also it is very important to know if a
patient has covered 19 versus the flu
because the prognosis is slightly
different
flu patients generally have a better
prognosis as opposed to cobain 19
and knowing this is also very important
another factor that that you would want
to know whether it is covet 19 or the
flu
is the decision around quarantining
these patients
if a patient is covet 19 positive strict
quarantining measures need to be
followed
to stop the spread with influenza while
it is important
not to have the influence of spread one
really does not need to follow such
strict quarantining procedures
that are similar that very similar to
what we see in covet
so whether it is through a patient
perspective or through a public health
perspective it is really really
important to know
why it is important to distinguish and
it is really through testing can one
really
differentiate between these diseases and
then that that's why it is very
important to different
distinguish between the three
so there's been a lot of recent news
around covid19 vaccines
um which i i do know are still at least
a couple of months out or more
um but there is a flu vaccine available
and always have you know has been
available for a while so
what role is the flu vaccination
potentially going to play
in combating a so-called twindemoc
the flu vaccine is available yearly and
this year more than any one should
certainly get the flu vaccine if it is
available
in some parts of the world the flu
vaccine is not easily available and is
expensive
but here in the united states the flu
vaccines are generally widely available
and one should certainly take it
as for whether flu vaccine will help in
combating against the co-weight
it will play an indirect role in
actually combating against
the flu in this twin damage what is
known about the flu vaccines is that
they are certainly effective against the
flu and even if one does get the flu
after vaccination
the symptoms are less severe than if one
did not take the vaccine as far as
coming to your question where there is a
direct effect
of flu vaccination on covet i don't
think there is enough data to show
one way or the other that there is the
effect of the flu vaccination on coed
and that is the reason why
pharmaceutical companies are striving
hard to develop the coverage vaccine
the two viruses are actually quite
different influenza virus belongs to the
ortho mix of veridae family
whereas cova-19 belongs to the
coronavirus family and there are
differences between the structures of
these two viruses
that each of these viruses require its
own specific vaccine
hopefully in the future there will be a
vaccine against covate19
and it will become part of the flu
vaccine so that with one part with one
vaccine
there can be protection against both
covet as well as the flu
that's really interesting and and kind
of exciting to hear about i know we're
all
anxiously awaiting a potential coveted
vaccine
so i've also read some neat articles
about acquired immunity and i have to
admit i don't know much about
this topic so i was hoping you could
explain a little bit more about what
acquired immunity is
and more about it in the context of
coven versus the flu
now this is a very interesting topic and
much remains to be known
the way i see it is covet is a very new
virus
um and we as humans have never been
exposed to this virus before
so there is no herd immunity against
coward with flu
it has been around for 100 years and we
as a species have evolved with it and
learn to live with it
with each passing year our body gets
used to this new strain of
blue virus and either through natural
infection or through an immunization
we get used to it similarly we have to
learn to live with covet too
covet just like other viruses will also
mutate and whether it is through natural
infection or when a vaccination
when we get a vaccine we our body will
mount an immune response to this virus
our immune system will know how to deal
with it and as a result the virus would
not be as virulent as it was when we
first saw it for the first time
this is the whole concept i acquired
immunity however having said that
we are at a very early stage in the
process and the journey with kuwait has
just begun
good so we're coming to the end of our
our time together
and i just wanted to kind of have an a
last opportunity for you to share any
additional thoughts
that you might have about the
implications of sars kobe 2 re-emergence
during flu season and any complications
we might see
from the overlap the one thing if i had
to say and look at kuwait and you know
there is not much you know there's not
much brightness to see there's not much
silver linings in this but if i had to
really see there's one bright spot that
is
it is that people are generally more
aware uh towards healthy habits
uh if people have to follow social
distancing practices
wearing mass and ppe and the greater
emphasis on flu vaccinations
it may actually help decrease the
incidence of flu this season
and it may be even actually milder than
years before
in fact there are actually been some
preliminary data that has come out from
places like japan and taiwan
and actually countries in the southern
hemisphere that just went through the
flu season
that it was that the flu season was
actually milder than years before
so we certainly hope that that is the
case but only time will tell
and you know we will see how this all
works out
thanks so much for your time today dr
gandhi i i know i really appreciate it i
learned a lot
and i'm looking forward to learning more
about thermo fisher's new solution when
it comes out
thanks everybody to joining us today and
we are so happy to have you
thank you so much my pleasure take care